17 octobre 1961
20h30 un étrange silence se fait dans
paris trente mille algériens venus des
bidonvilles surgissent soudain des
bouches de métro et s'avance sur les
boulevards sans amour sans un cri depuis
le début d'octobre le gouvernement
michel debré a décrété le couvre-feu
pour les maghrébins
chaque soir à partir de 20h30 c'est la
chasse au faciès
ce soir le fln a décidé de réagir c'est
la première fois depuis le début de la
guerre en 1954 que les algériens
prennent le risque de manifester ainsi
dans les rues de paris
passés les premiers moments de stupeur
c'est tout de suite la répression
quelques photos quelques mètres de films
aucun son c'est tout ce qu'il nous reste
de cette nuit de violence organisé une
nuit que les français pendant 20 ans ont
tout fait pour oublier comme en 1942
pour la grande rafle du vel d'hiv
les bus parisiens ont été mis à
contribution en quelques heures ils ont
transporté 11 1538 prisonniers
officiellement recensés vers le palais
des sports et le parc des expositions
porte de versailles
ils y resteront trois jours sans manger
croupissant dans leur ex commun mais
pour certains manifestants c'est sur le
pavé des boulevards que le voyage a pris
fin il y avait là un car de police
le gardien s'est affolé il a tiré
et juste ici un endroit où nous sommes
il y avait trois cadavres d'algériens
l'impression de gendarmes - c'est que le
peuple de paris ce soir là s'est
transformé en indicateurs de police en
auxiliaires de police montrait du doigt
et d'islam sur la jongle à monsieur à
jour en désignant les algériens qu'ils
allaient s'abriter dans des maisons
c'est ce jour là qu'un nouveau a fait
son apparition dans la langue française
ratonnades d'abord ayant commencé dire
on va les donner un coup de mitraillette
cantonade et descendez à lakanal entre
saint denis et jean de villiers et dans
un glass quoi le noir est très noir la
nuit à gérer on sort les soirs
l'horizon est après l'autre et l'avivo
ben guerir cartouches il est compté
après les enjeux télévion d'abord et
après nous il encore avancé encore le
cas mais net dans le noir et or je
t'aime ou cinq dans l'eau un institut
médico légal on a recensé 60 cadavres
d'algériens au conseil municipal de
paris claude bourdet demande à maurice
papon
s'il est vrai que cinq ans algériens ont
été tués à la préfecture de police le
préfet de police ne répond pas d'après
le fln il y a eu 200 morts et 400
disparus
d'après roger frey ministre de
l'intérieur de mort 64 blessés à
l'assemblée nationale claudius petit qui
pourtant n'appartient pas à l'opposition
de gauche
le pont violemment à partie cette mesure
d'un couvre feu
on s'engageait dans une politique
raciste qui était du même ordre que la
politique raciste nous avons connu sous
l'occupation alors une chose vous
frappez vous le dites dans votre
intervention c'est que la police ait agi
dans le calme
et oui parce qu'elle a agi dans le calme
dans le cadre d'une consigne dans le
cadre de presse que dans le cadre de
quelque chose qui on peut pas dire
qu'ils étaient couverts mais qui était
la conclusion fatale d'une décision
malheureuse pour quelques tombes au
cimetière musulman de bobigny combien de
morts sans sépulture